firstly address the issue of the
Hillsborough report the Hillsborough
disaster was a devastating tragedy and
we recognized the significant impact
that it continues to have on those
affected on their families and on their
communities the timing of the
government's response has been impacted
by the need to avoid the risk of
prejudice during any criminal
proceedings which are related to
Hillsborough nonetheless work has been
underway has been undertaken across all
relevant government departments and
organizations to carefully consider and
address the points of learning which are
included in the Bishops report and to
whom they are directed as the National
Police Chief's council is independent of
government it is for them to publish
their own response independently of
government and that's a step that I
welcome but the government remains
absolutely committed to responding to
The Bishop's report as soon as
practicable and our Focus now is on
engaging in a meaningful way with the
bereaved families of the Hillsborough
disaster prior to publishing the
government's overarching response it's
critical that lessons can be learned
from their experience and that they are
not lost as we move forward